[Music]
and they certainly did after Laverne and
Shirley while Cindy Williams and Penny
Marshall returned to TV and 2016 to tape
a special episode of Garry Marshalls Odd
Couple reboot yeah this was all to honor
Penny's brother who died that same year
and I was fortunate enough to be on the
set of The Odd Couple that day as Cindy
revealed secrets about their hit show
[Music]
that famous opening was actually an idea
of Gary's they shot it late at night at
the studio where they filmed the show he
said penny teach Cindy that little dance
she did on the way to school with your
chums and he said action and we did it
once and I didn't get it the up and down
she'll kneel schlemazel and so the
second take I got it and he said okay
that's good we're out of here Gary also
created happy days in fact Laverne and
Shirley very first TV appearance was
when they guest-starred on the show as
Fonzie and Ritchie's dates so my brother
called and asked if we would play these
parts so Cheryl why do you think of this
kid you've been with words oh it's nice
tuna tycoon their own series ran from
1976 to 1983 the two were roommates who
worked in a Milwaukee brewery we were
hard-working girls who try to make the
rent we try to do everything just to
survive and I think people in America
who could identify with that keys to
their success
we're the sight-gags we did a lot of
physical comedy which was not common in
that time years ago wanted to be a stunt
girl penny and she worked as a stunt
girl in some terrible movies penny did
get hurt a couple of times she did over
the years et has been there and Cindy
and Penny have done reunion specials
they even recreated that famous opening
the whole cast reunited in 2000 to
support Squiggy
David Lander who suffers from MS it's
like good old friends you could not see
them for four or five years and then see
the minutes like eight seconds has
passed my sister penny is not good at
getting up in the morning
but this she got up it wasn't the day
that I wouldn't be up by after work
today actually but not at this hour and
some 40 years after becoming TV icons
penny and Cindy had still remained close
penny and I see each other all the time
don't tell me that Laverne and Shirley
really are Laverne and Shirley we watch
TV together
[Music]
you